a lot of people like to say i love you
on valentine's day with sweets but there
are other ways of saying it without
using sugar joining us now is stephen
parker from black tap craft burgers and
beer which is inside the venetian how
you doing buddy good how are you today
good to see you man good to see you too
okay i hear you've got a sandwich that
makes your heart skip a beat what is it
yeah it's our truffle hot honey chicken
sandwich it's spicy it's delicious it's
sweet it keeps you coming back for more
every time a little white barbecue and
kosher pickles on there it's great it's
great you're going to assemble it for us
here today i'm going to show you how to
make it we're going to go through all
the ingredients all that good stuff
before we get into it tell us more about
the restaurant what's the vibe like
there the vibe's really cool you know
we're into street art a lot of graffiti
in the restaurant early 90s hip hop
we're about making memories whether it's
you know about our milkshakes our
specials our award-winning burgers um
this month we're doing our red velvet
classic cake shake that we're running
all month we're also running our uh
crazy shake our red velvet crazy shake
we're running from uh february 11th
through february 14th we'll get into
these crazy shakes here in a second
let's let's assemble the sandwich what
goes into this thing so first um we put
our truffle hot honey on our chicken
sandwich this is hot the spicy it's some
cayenne and some black truffle oil some
honey all mixed together heat it up i
love it give a little spice and we have
a red pepper jam so add some burrito
chili powder
bell red pepper some vinegar some sugar
we cook it all down so it's like a nice
thick consistency there look at that
you're a
great know i'm really good at unlv
hospitality school
and you're a temple guy another temple
guy yes sir what kind of sauce you put
on top of this we're going to do a white
barbecue mm-hmm and so it's not typical
okay what's what's what's a white
barbecue what makes it white bbq is a
mayonnaise mayonnaise-based barbecue
right there's no like brown sugar
there's no ketchup it's basically the
barbecue sauce without the ketchup right
okay most brown barbecue sauces are a
ketchup base all right so this is just
completely white spices a little honey a
little hickory smoke in there
and then we put a little kosher pickles
on top for the crunch some acid
um cuts through all that sweetness
now who came up with this this idea of
the sandwich oh this is nice this is
your creation how long were you in the
lab making this thing i'm not in the lab
you know i think i ate something that
had like a smoky pepper jam on it and
i'm like you know that's really good is
that how that works as a chef you taste
something like you know what i can do oh
yeah taste stuff you figure out what
you're really like and you find
something you're like you know what this
would really work right so something
like this really works because you have
a little spice in it sweet you can eat
it with your honey you could share it on
valentine's day you get nice and sticky
eat it with your honey i like the thai
rice
it's good you like how i threw that in
you're good yeah hey let's talk about
your shakes because i hear they're just
insane our shakes are crazy so
over-the-top milkshakes is what we're
into you know it's one of the things we
do at blacktap um we like bringing
people back to their childhoods whether
it's a cookie whether it's a piece of
brown yeah cinnabon on top and then you
know like i said in february a big huge
piece of red velvet cake with a red
velvet base milkshakes we actually take
red velvet cake batter mix it with the
mix vanilla ice cream and that's the
shake base for this crazy red velvet
shake that we're running february 11
through february 14th i love it man
gotta wrap it up here real quick what
are some of the things you have here
before we wrap it up so this is a red
pepper jam and we talked about smoky and
spicy a little bit sweet right this is
our white barbecue
brussel sprouts we got some brussels
sprouts with our tahini sauce this is
our 2021 new york city food winning
alberta burger bash our steakhouse kobe
burger with 81 sauce and there's our
korean wings served with buttermilk dill
award-winning food stephen thank you so
much thank you so much is where they
find you guys venetians where they find
us i appreciate it man thanks man temple
in the house rocky we'll send it over to
you thank you